series 3 is about to start for Game of
Thrones we're here to talk about Game of
Thrones exactly oh nice and dramatic yes
we're looking forward to much more
dramatic merits the new season for you
but yes yeah yeah it's really good
there's some great stuff this year stuff
that necessarily may not be in the books
which is fantastic I think it's a really
welcomed addition makes the show a lot
tighter more entertaining and they're
really ups the stakes for the forest and
the Tyrells and you know the dynasties
as well you wait till you see how
Charlie dance dies that is really funny
somebody in the street who've been
reading all the books you know it's got
great deaths singing I said Oh have I
what is the manner of my death and he
told me it's quite spectacular
I'm not going to tell you what it is I
think it's going to be a terrific season
it's going to be the best yet and
because everything really kicks off you
know and obviously I can't see what's
going to happen but it's going to be
very exciting and very surprising in
season 3 Branagh sort of becoming a
leader and he knows where he wants to go
and what he wants to do so I think bran
is picked up on water on what maester
Luwin taught him and he is almost
becoming mr. lewin we meet some new
characters some new characters come into
the show and and you know just gonna
have to wait and see there are some two
two very popular new characters who are
coming in who who come in and sit in
book two in the books but they spend
until season three and they bring a
really interesting new aspect to the
whole brand storyline what can we look
forward to from your character um more
horrid treatment of my little dwarf son
I'm afraid I spend a lot of time
shouting at him and cheating him
appallingly
which is quite upsetting because he's
one of the most delightful men and a
wonderful actor
and I just treat him like dirt it's
awful I just created a couple of very
nice scenes in the series three about
being Oh about not being as old as I
seem Tywin sausage mayor says how long
you've been getting away with this for
years and it's ridiculous why do you do
it I say to survive I virtually say I
want to die in my own time not somebody
else's I know you know my time will come
very soon because I'm very old but
because I'm 104 for God's sake what a
very long life expectancy and and he
accepts that and he he acts accordingly
it's gonna be bigger it's gonna be just
when you thought that you couldn't be
surprised or shocked by the series it
will shock you and surprise you even
further than you could possibly imagine
and the development of the characters
goes in a place where it just I mean it
this is what's so brilliant about the
series is that
you just don't know what's going to
happen and george RR martin is a
ruthless and when you have a story where
no one is safe it means that anything
can happen
you